just curious about the Academy Awards
did you go did you go to the Academy
well I went to the very hip Vanity Fair
dinner yeah which you have been to yeah
clearly not this year but I was invited
it's very it's very all elegant Graydon
Carter I can't believe they even had it
when I cancelled yes Mexico must have
gone crazy seeing you with your height
walk around I don't walk like Vanna Mari
what are you describing you're
describing some credits and they're
saying look I thought dear the Dead was
later on I know no it was fantastic
there's so many stars there I mean every
table it's like you know you know one
drone attack and Trump could eliminate
90% of his problem that everyone he
hates is in one room everyone he hates
her and how about that moment at the end
in C oh my god the whole roomis we
everyone was stunned in the audience
couldn't tell because of the Botox but
[Applause]
it was one of the most awkward moments
in the history of anything I've ever
seen on television it insane yes truly
insane and I kept thinking you know
Jimmy Fallon's prompter Widow the a
Golden Globes Mike went out at the
Grammys and now this and I just thought
to myself well played mr. Putin you're
serious that Putin is now going after
our exclusive I do wow he's good if you
can do the election he can do an award
did you like this year's movies let's go
through this this year's movies I'm
curious how you felt about them like
hacks are rich well I just thought it
was heroic for Andrew Garfield to bring
back Mel Gibson's career I just think
here's death-defying yeah another land I
love love you you love Lalo and
I mean it proves that first of all white
people and jazz we knew that but if you
stick to your dreams uh-huh and you you
keep your ideal you could get to sleep
with them the stone that's very nice
hidden figures did you see that hidden
that was hidden figures is a brilliant I
haven't seen it I believe that's about
president Trump's income taxes all right
like having Bill Maher on I know without
the colony yeah yeah
you